[Music]
as russia unleashes relentless attacks
against ukraine u.s president joe biden
met with his national security team and
made an emergency request to congress to
allocate 6.4 billion dollars for
military and humanitarian aid the former
president of ukraine is pleading for
western allies for help we need the
anti-tech we need anti-aircraft
we just need to increase our defensive
capability to stop the crazy
aggressor
in europe
humanitarian aid is desperately needed
too for the ukrainians fleeing their
country mostly women and children they
moved out without nothing even i'm sorry
like no socks no toothbrush nothing
protests announcing russia's invasion of
ukraine have erupted around the world
from the white house to tokyo many
russian citizens are disgusted by
president vladimir putin's brutality we
hate what's just happening right now in
our country
british prime minister boris johnson
says the world hasn't seen anything like
this since the second world war it's a
generation or more since we witnessed
such bloodshed in europe
we hoped we would never have to see such
sites again
pressure is building on nato member
turkey to close off passage of russian
warships ukrainians in that country fear
they will never see their loved ones
again i'm calling them every 10 15
minutes i don't know what is happening
there right now
just stand up and do thomson to protect
our families
seven thousand additional u.s troops are
on their way to europe to help protect
nato allies and join nato's response
force as concerns grow this war could
spread beyond ukraine's borders there's
a historic nature to all this this is
the first time that the alliance has
employed these high readiness forces
international pressure is mounting for
putin to end this unprovoked war but
russian forces are continuing on their
bloody mission as the death toll for
both countries climbs
jennifer johnson global news washington